what is Burke Ramsey really know about
his sister's murder and the 911
where were you when that phone call was
made to my bed dr. Phil pulled no
punches with the noun
twenty-nine-year-old Burke about his
sister
did you ever sexually abuse JonBenet no
absolutely not in this never-before-seen
interview footage a nine year-old Burke
is seen talking to a police psychologist
just weeks after his sister's murder
see how Burke reacts while watching this
clip of himself drawing a family picture
that did not include JonBenet did you
consciously not draw job today I don't
really remember what was going through
my head but she was gone so I and dryer
what do you think you're saying this I
think I felt a little awkward talking
about it and I think it was just
something that I thought everyone knew I
spoke with dr. Phil after this interview
about his reactions to Burke Ramsey
there are times when he's talking about
very heavy dark content but yet he's
smiling I'll let people make up their
own mind about why that is he has very
strong ideas about what has happened and
what has been said and he leaves
absolutely nothing to the imagination
about where he stands on all of this and
that interview is riveting and dr. villa
has more with Burke tomorrow